[Music]
there are various estimates of how big a
drain on the world's resources the
digital economy is one data point is
that one percent of the world's carbon
emissions are created by people just
streaming video over their phones or on
their PCS smartphones computers data
centers and all the digital activities
we take for granted are estimated to use
around seven percent of the world's
electricity and that's only going to get
worse as we rely more and more on our
devices
probably the best way to look at that is
what's going on in data centers these
are these giant factories full of
computers that are processing all of the
information that you generate these
giant data centers are on a course to be
using much more electricity by perhaps
the end of the decade clearly that kind
of a drain is just not sustainable we
need new Solutions we need novel
Solutions scientists and startups around
the world are developing low energy
computer chips which could be better for
the environment and upgrade the
intelligence of our digital devices
everything's tied to computers getting
better it could be Finance it could be
chemical engineering name your field so
my goal with since founding the company
has been to develop a new Computing
Paradigm a new technology platform that
will allow computers to continue to make
progress
it's not only about design but also
sending them for fabrication testing
them and making system prototypes for
various applications the focus of the
application would be reducing the energy
consumption to the minimum level
it's a very high risk High reward type
problem
so if we're successful then we'll
transform this industry maybe this
enormous leap in this field
[Music]
from space Hardware to toasters almost
everything in modern life depends on
silicon-based semiconductors called
chips
they're the things that make electronic
items smart
at a very fundamental level as
semiconductors are made up of what's
called transistors and these are the
absolutely microscopic digital switches
the on or offs on or off means one or
zero in the digital realm say a modern
Graphics chip will have tens of billions
of transistors on it and this is
something that's the size of your
thumbnail so how do we get all of these
tiny switches onto something relatively
small where we do that by building up
layers of material on a disk of silicon
scraping off patterns into those
materials layering on other materials
until we have these tiny circuits that
give the chip its function
for half a century the semiconductor
industry has made chips exponentially
faster and better by shrinking the size
of transistors turning room-sized
computers into pocket-sized smartphones
propelling the digital Revolution
clearly new technology is presenting
both management and staff with an
ever-growing range of choices about how
and where work will be done in the
future but traditional competing is
reaching its limit state-of-the-art
mass-produced chips are made with what's
called five nanometer technology a
dimension that's smaller than a virus
and materials inside some devices are
already one atom thick meaning they
can't be made any smaller and we're
reaching the limits of physics we're
reaching the limits of energy density
the increasing consensus in the chip
industry is that these advances that
we've got from Silicon are beginning to
come to an end so that if we really want
to take advantage of the full potential
of artificial intelligence and the
absolute ocean of data that we're all
creating today we're going to need new
materials we're going to need new
programming models we're going to need
new versions of computers
my personal first time about learning
and discovering what a carbon attitude
was was when I was just about finishing
up a college undergraduate and I saw a
presentation by the Vice President of
research of
of IBM immediately I was
thought it was very special
a carbon nanotube is a material made
entirely of carbon atoms the carbon
atoms are arranged in a tube
imagine taking a sheet of carbon atoms
and rolling them into a tube and then
making that tube smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller until the diameter
of that tube was just a few atoms it's
extremely small which is about 100 000
times smaller than the diameter of an
eyelash and 100 times smaller than the
virus
the really cool thing about nanotubes is
they conduct the electricity better than
just about any other material that's
ever been discovered electrons will move
along the length of a nanotube faster
than they do in Silicon and that means
you can get ultimately faster switching
between on and off States you can make
faster computer chips
you could turn them on and off with less
voltage
and that means they use less electricity
less power than silicon in theory
nanotubes will be able to do a thousand
times better than silicon same
computational capabilities 1000 times
less power
another Advantage is that carbon
nanotubes can be processed at a low
temperature so layers of nanotubes can
be built on top of one another
silicon has to be processed at an
extremely high temperature which makes
3D layers much harder
if you really think about a city what
happens when you run out of real estate
in a city is you build up you build
skyscrapers you build into the third
dimension and so if you can't make the
transistor smaller then you could
improve your computer chip by making
more transistors by making multiple
layers of transistors on top of other
transistors
[Music]
since the 1990s when nanotubes were
first invented in Japan different
methods have been developed to
mass-produce them
but every process creates two types of
nanotubes metallic ones and
semiconducting ones
if you would like a copper wire it's
stuck in
[Music]
the need only semiconducting nanotubes
to really make the antique electronics
work
the molecules and polymers
that can be mixed in with the carbon
nanotube powder which is this Tangled
mess of nanotubes and those molecules
and polymers will stick to just the
semiconducting ones and not the metallic
ones or they'll stick differently and
then you could sort the nanotubes and
separate them based on these differences
initially in a powder there's about 67
percent of the nanotubes are
semiconducting but using these chemical
approaches we could extract over 99.99
of the semiconducting nanotubes
after the semiconducting nanotubes have
been extracted they float around in a
solution and so the next challenge is to
line them up neatly on a silicon wafer
which can then be turned into a computer
chip
carbon nanotubes really got me hooked
and excited right from the beginning I
mean they really have the opportunity to
potentially revolutionize Electronics
this challenge of aligning them in these
highly packed highly aligned arrays has
really been frustrating the field of
carbon nanotube Electronics since their
discovery
during my PhD I was kind of tasked with
actually determining you know how we can
better align carbon nanotubes we just
found you know kind of by accident that
when we layer carbon nanotube ink or
inks where carbon nanotubes are
dissolved in Solutions like organic
solvents if we layer that carbon
nanotube ink on water then
instantaneously those carbon nanotubes
will collect and confine at that ink
water interface and that high ordering
and induced ordering by themselves
really helps to align the carbon
nanotubes
what you're saying here is a aligned
array of hundreds or thousands of carbon
nanotubes so you can see individual
nanotubes these light colored regions
and then the dark colored region is the
substrate because they're all really
well aligned with respect to each other
occasionally there's a misaligned
nanotube in this uh
then we need to improve our our
manufacturing process to eliminate those
instances
the biggest current challenge is being
able to achieve that high alignment and
extremely uniform arrays across you know
300 millimeter Wafers which is an
industry standard of silicon Wafers
before they start changing silicon to
integrate carbon nanotubes instead
if we can overcome these challenges if
we can make these aligned nanotube
Wafers the major players in Industry
will really jump into this field and
could just progress at that point can be
very rapid
the technique isn't perfect yet but it's
already in advance for carbon nanotube
research
Michael and Catherine have founded a
company with an aim to solve remaining
challenges
but many more breakthroughs are needed
before nanotube transistors have even a
chance of replacing silicon it
absolutely shows promise but it's been
showing promise for 20 years there are
many issues you know how robust are
these devices but more importantly can
you manufacture them
the semiconductor industry is based on
Silicon transistors and enormous sums
have already been invested in
infrastructure to manufacture that
technology
plants have a price tag of 20 billion
dollars take years to build and need to
be run for 24 hours a day to turn a
profit change will be difficult without
a guarantee that carbon nanotubes would
be cheaper silicon's been around a long
time people know how to use it they know
how to program it they know how to mass
manufacture it it's still in terms of
the economics the winner and until those
economics change nothing is going to
replace it
I've always been obsessed with computers
you know I had an opportunity to work in
Industry at a large Semiconductor
Company for a number of years
and I got to see there some of the
fundamental challenges associated with
continuing to shrink transistors and I
found that to be
um not a very exciting future
so my goal with light matter since
founding the company has been to develop
a new Computing Paradigm a new
technology platform that allows you to
do calculations using photonic devices
when Electronics uses electrons that's
the medium of transfer that's what
represents the data photonics is using
photons which is the basic constituency
of light so for example
a fiber optic cable that spans the
Pacific Ocean is using light to transmit
information why is it using light well
it's because the energy required to show
the electrons along a copper cable would
be absolutely enormous and you would
just have too much signal Decay so if
you can convert that information into
photons you can send it faster and with
less Energy overhead so that's obviously
a desirable thing
there's nothing faster than the speed of
light so when you think about the
latency between when you make a query
and when a photonic computer gives you
an answer it's really at the fundamental
limit for how fast you could do these
things
electrical wires there's a certain
amount of time that it takes for them to
turn on and off and every time you do it
takes a lot of energy to do this to turn
this wire off and on now with a photonic
computer and photonics in general you
have a type of wire that doesn't take
very long at all femtoseconds maybe even
Auto seconds to turn on it takes almost
no energy other than any light that's
lost while the optical signal is
propagating through that wire
you have another great property with
photonics which is that you can send
multiple data streams through this
photonic wire encoded in different
colors or wavelengths all at the same
time so you have massively parallel
computation and communication through
these nearly perfect wires
the idea of silicon photonics has been
around again for a long time
the problem comes with changing those
electrons based signals into photons so
the traditional way of doing that is to
have all of these other pieces of
equipment that are expensive and use
lots of energy to do that so looking
photonics is well maybe we can just
design a chip that directly deals in
both electrons and photons that we can
have you know the benefits of Both
Worlds and that's what was supposedly on
the cusp of doing again it's been
promised for a long time it's going to
change the world or has been about to
change the world for a long time and it
hasn't yet
but light matter still believes silicon
photonics is going to happen and it's
harnessing existing laser Technologies
used in the telecoms and semiconductor
processing Industries their chips are
specifically being made for AI
applications like chat Bots and
self-driving cars the startup plans to
launch their first photonic computer
later this year
one of their current products is an
interconnect which enables chips to talk
to each other
it could help solve energy consumption
issues in data centers and potentially
bring down costs
in these huge factories processors are
closely arranged together so they can
communicate at high speeds but this also
generates a massive amount of heat
so not only do you have to put the power
in to power all of these components but
then you have to use an enormous amount
of power to actually cool them down to
stop them literally melting
what this company is trying to do is to
come up with interconnects and ways of
connecting components that use light
rather than electrons over wires so that
means in theory that you could have a
processor in one room memory in another
storage in another and that would help
with the density and and the power and
the Heat and that's definitely a
solution that's being tried by numerous
companies but we're still waiting for
that to show you know practical everyday
results and be widely adopted
human brain is very efficient your brain
operates all the time it doesn't
dissipate more than 10 to 20 watts which
is very small value
to solve the problem of Rubin Cube so
the amount of energy which is required
to learn and then operate is very low as
compared to the actual systems just
solving the problem put learning aside
that itself will need thousands of
processors to become parallel and then
dissipate a lot of power which can go
beyond megawatt
these scientists in India have been
trying to build low energy chips
mimicking the way the human brain works
for years
the human brain is packed with neuron
cells that communicate with each other
through electrical pulses known as
spikes each neuron releases molecules
that act as Messengers and control if
the electrical pulse is passed along the
chain
this transmission happens in the gaps
between neurons which are called
synapses
neurons and synapses they are
fundamentally different from the way
computers compute computers use
transistors which are binary they do
zero one on off the brain sort of does a
similar thing except that it works in
analog it's also partly stochastic
a neuron May Spike or may not Spike
depending upon inherent internal
randomness
the brain itself doesn't like to do
repetitive things it likes to do
everything with slight variance this
sort of enables creativity it sort of
enables problem solving
and the youngster's creative imagination
is not neglected
once there was a bear that was twice the
size of the Earth and lived on the Sun
the connections are different
so if you look at a computer chip every
transistor roughly talks to about 10
transistors
every neuron on the other hand talks to
about 10 000 other neurons
and that's literally what makes it super
parallel
neurons whose time as a token of
information computers don't understand
time per se they just sort of you know
work with digital numbers and do
mathematical operations
to mimic the architecture of our brain
more closely the team designed an
artificial neural net based on the
biological neural networks in our brain
each artificial neuron is built with a
few silicon transistors and connected to
other neurons we try to mimic the
auditory cortex so the auditory cortex
has this neurons which are connected in
random and that sounds weird but it
turns out it serves a very important
function which is in speech processing
what we are doing is that there are
recurrent connections which means that
the neuron could go to any neuron
including itself
creating some sort of loopy Pathways
which are fairly random and these Loops
are part of the architecture they are
called liquid state machine they
naturally are able to process time
series like when you hear speech which
is sort of occurs in time
we are doing some analog compute there
is some noise also in the neurons so
there could be some stochasticity
in their traditional or conventional
competition platform everything is
digital everything is defined based on
logic 1 and 0. analog computers which
are eventually signals which can have
any value to would be able to get more
complexity at the same time more
functionality in the operation
here we have our new network chip which
is on the dashboard so what we'll do is
we'll speak to the computer and that
will sort of convert the speech into
spikes it's going to get processed in
the chip we run the code one
so it detects a one
this neuromorphic chip has been able to
recognize speech using a fraction of the
energy used by a traditional chip
just like biological neurons the
artificial neurons wait for inputs and
only Spike when data comes in and that
means lower energy consumption
each neuron is also highly efficient by
using a quantum mechanics phenomenon
called band to band tunneling
so electrons are still able to pass
through transistors with very low
electric current
Ling is nothing that humans essentially
have experienced for if you have a human
being that has to cross over a hill the
human being has to walk up the hill burn
energy and then walk down which again
Burns energy and so there is no way for
you to cross this barrier without using
up energy if you make this hill thinner
and thinner narrower and narrower until
it goes to the size scale on the order
of say a few electron wavelengths at
which point an electron doesn't need to
go above the barrier to surmount it it
can in principle tunnel through it which
means it will sort of disappear on one
side and appear on the other side
magically
if you take a transistor there is a same
idea that when it turns on we have a
barrier that we sort of reduce and when
we want to turn it off we increase the
barrier that's when you expect no
current to go through
but
that is not true by quantum mechanics
so even through a barrier when it's
narrow enough
electrons can sort of quote unquote
tunnel through it
so far there are 36 artificial neurons
on the chip
and their energy consumption is
remarkably close to biological neurons
if we want to approach
the number of neurons which are already
in human brain so we need billions of
them and therefore we need to reduce the
energy per Spike generated by a single
neuron as much as possible
Intel one of the world's biggest chip
makers has been working on brain
inspired chips for seven years
they've released two versions of their
neuromorphic research chip Logan the
latest one is only 32 square millimeters
in size but contains up to a million
neurons
the company said luihi has demonstrated
multiple applications including
recognizing hazardous odors and enabling
robotic arms to feel in the near term
based on the most recent results we've
had with luihi I would say that solving
optimization problems are are the most
exciting application things like
planning navigating you can think of it
of solving the shortest path in a map
for example if you want to get from
point A to point B these kind of
optimization problems are conventionally
really compute heavy but we found that
on a neuromorphic architecture we can
reduce the computational demands by
orders of magnitude so over a 10 times
speed up as well as over a thousand
times energy reduction
probably the majority of the groups that
are working with low ehi sees robotics
as kind of the long-term best
application domain for neuromorphic
chips after all brains evolved in nature
to control bodies and to deal with real
world stimulus respond to it in real
time and adapt to the you know
unpredictable aspect of the real world
and if you think about robotics today
they perform very rigidly prescribed
tasks but if you want to deploy a robot
into the real world we really don't have
the technology yet to make them as agile
as adaptive as we really would like and
so that's where we see neuromorphic
chips really thriving
Intel and its collaborators have used
the Luigi chip to power iCup a humanoid
robot designed to learn in a way that
children might
this icub robot is intended to interact
with the environment as opposed to being
pre-trained with static data sets
beforehand
so using kind of psychatic motions
moving the eyeballs it can trace through
and detect change or edges in the
objects in front of this robot and using
a fully neuromorphic Paradigm we're able
to design a network that understands and
learns new object classes even at
different angles and different poses it
adds to its understanding it's kind of
dictionary of understand objects over
time
what is this called
that's a mouse
oh I see this is a mouse let me have a
look at that
can you show me the mouse
here is the mouse
so far all of this technology is at an
early stage
but to fight climate change and power
the progress of civilization we need at
least one of them to be a breakthrough
Greener chips absolutely have to happen
people are concerned about the
environmental impact people are
concerned about efficiency people are
concerned about the results and the way
that chips can impact Modern Life so
there's been you know an absolute
blossoming of investment in chip
startups and trying these things this is
definitely the time of of great ideas
will they all be successful absolutely
not but now I would say more than ever
there is a chance that out there in in
some corner of the world there is a chip
startup that will be everywhere within
maybe the next 10 years
you can't get your enjoyments from only
the successes in science you need to get
your enjoyment from just enjoying
solving hard problems and so if you fail
that is just part of the process of
eventually finding a solution
[Music]